seduction is in a high form of power
because you make people feel pleasure
you make them feel excited or interested
in you and then their resistance to your
ideas slowly lowers and you have the
ability to influence them and to move
them in the direction that you want if
you yell at them like do this do that
they resent it and for good reason but
if you're a subtler people will do what
you want or go in your direction without
ever even realizing what are the
qualities of a great Seducer what makes
for a great Seducer is very simple I can
summarize it very simply you are outer
directed when you meet somebody for the
first time you're not having that
internal monologue going does she like
me or does he like me my trust well you
turn it off you're outer directed and
you're listening to them and you're
entering their spirit and you're hearing
them say things that give you idea of
what they're missing in life of what
they want you're absorbing it you're
entering into their spirit and then you
can reflect back to them you can give
them gifts you can take them to places
that show that you're attentive to them
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because as a young
entrepreneur I struggle to keep my
business going I had no friends I had no
mentors I had no role models and the
thing that saved me was learning from
the success stories of famous
entrepreneurs and in their stories I got
motivation and I also got strategies for
what I could do to grow my business and
not stay stuck and I still need their
stories of motivation today so today
let's learn how you can build your
confidence enjoy
look at how we are in our day-to-day
life
normally people never pay us attention
they're always so self-absorbed they're
never thinking about us they're you I've
been the times where you get the sense
that people are actually interested in
who you are as an individual is pretty
rare
if you give that feeling to someone it's
incredibly powerful because we all want
to be validated we all want to be
recognized
so what the Seducer is not someone who's
all worried about him or herself and
thinking they're involved in the other
person they're absorbed like a sponge
inside their psychology inside their
world we live in a culture where people
think you don't you shouldn't have to
put effort into something like love and
romance you should just be who you are
man I don't have to put on a role I'd
have to play a game that's manipulative
no I'm sorry
love and romance is something that is
almost biological
if you look at animals and mating
rituals they're incredibly elaborate
seduction is a mating ritual and so the
worst thing you can feel is that this
person isn't putting any effort into
something
let's just say it's it's uh it's from
the woman's point of view this man
he just shows up wearing jeans and his
usual sloppy outfit he doesn't combs
hair
et cetera et cetera Etc
he takes me to the pub for dinner on our
first date
you know he he's not thinking about me
he's not willing to put any effort into
it if he's not willing to put any effort
into it
what's it going to be like three months
down the line when he completely takes
me for granted which is what happens in
a relationship am I not important enough
right whereas the ability to have a
little bit of effort to think of it as
kind of theater and drama and that
there's nothing evil about it so
I'm going to dress nicely I'm gonna I
just have to be fancy just that I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna put some effort
into how I look I'm going to take her to
a place that isn't is you know I'm not
talking about candlelights and roses and
that kind of crap doesn't that you can
be creative it can be somewhere that
that's scuzzy that's on the wrong side
of town but it's different and it's
appealing to and you put some thought
into it there's a reason you're taking
her there let seduction is a language
it's not a language of words it's a
language of gestures that we're paying
attention to
we're paying attention to people's body
language we're paying attention to their
actions to the things that they never
say being with people is a skill being a
social animal although there's a part
that comes naturally if you spend all of
your time here you're losing that skill
of how to respond to people's body
language you know half of the thing is
you're sitting in a bar opposite let's
say it's a woman
and how she crosses her legs how she
sips her drink how she looks at you how
she touches her hair she's signaling
things it's a language it's a beautiful
language
right you have to learn it and you're
not going to learn it here because you
can't you have to be in person has to be
skinned skin you have to get a feel of
what other people are thinking and
feeling and we're actually really really
good at that humans have that's what
makes us human it's called mirror
neurons I can sense what's going on in
your mind I can read your body language
you have to get out in the world and you
have to be put yourself physically out
there and try and try and try and have
rejection
and I know it sounds awful but it is a
skill in a way where you're learning how
to like understand and deal with people
and and and understand that what they're
who they are and get inside their Spirit
it takes time and effort and patience we
evolved for hundreds of thousands of
years before language existed right and
our earliest ancestors depended on the
group for their survival and getting
along and their powers came from
observing other people and their body
language you could read it so it's a
skill that's wired into US wired into
our brains it's very unique skill that
we humans have it's just that you don't
learn that when you're a child when
you're two years old you have it because
your life depends on it
you you have to see what if your mother
is is loving you or is or your father is
kind to you because if not you know you
could be abandoned your life depends on
you're great at reading that and
children have are incredibly Adept at
picking up body language so if someone
is fake
if someone's an imposter they hate being
around children because children see
through you you know like you know like
radar right because they're so attuned
to it you had that skill when you were
very young but you lost it because you
became so oriented with words and you
became so self-absorbed that you're not
paying attention
but it's extremely important right so
the whole body is involved in it so
you've got to first stop thinking about
people's words so much
because the one thing about words
unfortunately is people can lie they can
say whatever they want they can say I
love your screenplay that was fantastic
you were great in that movie I thought
you were great senator they can say
anything to please to flatter to control
you but body language man it doesn't lie
right so I talk in that book about the
eyes and the fake smile the fake smile
is something you see every single day
but you're not paying attention it's
like
um
it's kind of tight right it's like
yeah right but a real smile
you're the whole face gets animated and
there's a little crinkly thing here as
your face as you as it lights up and
your eyes light up it's it's hard to
even put into words but it's there you
can see it it's real it's not faked
knowing the difference between a fake
and a real smile is really important in
seduction in business or whatever to
know if someone is like yeah
I like that idea you know they don't
really they're saying that to please you
they actually hate your idea you master
that language you can start deciphering
all these people are giving you
the face you can disguise it a little
bit actors know that but you know what
you can't fake it's your voice
if you're nervous not even the finest
actors in the world can fake that your
voice betrays so many things about you
it betrays your weakness it portrays
your lack of confidence or it portrays
the other quality Etc right so pay
really attention to the tone of people's
voices to how fast they talk people who
talk fast are very nervous someone who's
talks I know I'm probably talking a
little too fast here sorry
oh my mind races so I can't do that
normally I don't talk so fast but um
you know you talk slowly you have a
certain tone you have a certain
intonation that kind of reveals
confidence okay
body language posture you were talking
about pecking right when you go and look
at a meeting of people in in a business
meeting
you'll see all the employees kind of
leaning forward nervous and you'll see
the boss kind of leaning back arms first
like this you know I'm the powerful one
you come to me I'm the leader I'm the
I'm the top dog or she it's a woman I
don't need to be like this I'm like this
body language reveals a lot about
leadership qualities
etc etc etc
you know if you go you're at a party
and you come up to someone that you're
meeting for the first time and they're
talking to you and you notice that their
feet are angling away from you
that means that they're not really
interested they're looking for any
moment to try and walk away and Escape
they're not really into you whereas
their feet are facing you they're
engaged they want to talk to you right
rule number two is build your confidence
with Mel Robbins in terms of my own
experience with getting serious about
creating the skill of confidence is it's
a game changer
the more that you build confidence in
your life the greater the risks you're
going to take and that's critical in
business in life for fulfillment I also
have the ability to say no and not even
be bothered by what other people are
going to feel why because I have the
skill of confidence it also makes you an
incredible negotiator because you
realize you would rather be respected
than be liked and see this kind of need
to be liked or to look good is part of
the reason why you doubt yourself all
the time I want you to bring that power
back internally that's what the skill of
confidence does and you'll also be able
to recognize when you're afraid of
something and that that fear is just
kind of bullshitting your head and you
have a choice you don't have to let fear
stop you anymore and that's where the
skill of confidence comes in and the
same is going to be true for you
so I think it kind of begs the question
if confidence is something that we all
want why is it so hard to master I'll
tell you why
because when it comes to the research
around confidence it is some of the most
dry
boring no offense to the confidence
researchers and writers out there but
I'm talking if you have trouble sleeping
just print out a study about confidence
that'll that that'll put you into deep
REM sleep it's also confusing and even
Google isn't much of a help on this
topic if you search how to be confident
you know what the top results one of
them says be true to you what the hell
does that even mean be true to you and
honestly be true to you that is not what
the research says the problem and why
it's hard for people to develop the
skill of confidence is the research has
not been boiled down into tactical
information that you can apply to your
day-to-day life and that's where your
friend Mel Robbins comes in so here's
your first assignment on today's podcast
because you know we're not just
listening here this is a doing podcast
and we're going to make this tactical
and relevant immediately
assignment number one be selfish as you
listen I want you to listen a particular
way I want you to listen and think
what's in it for me and so let me ask
you a question to help you get really
selfish
if you had more confidence like I could
go
and boom you have more confidence than
you've ever had in your entire life
how would your life be different
how would your future be different
now Heather has already shared that she
has this awesome promotion which she
clearly earned I mean businesses don't
just give those out as Charity if a
business has promoted or hired you they
believe in your ability to execute but
now she's freaking out
she doesn't have the confidence
now when you think about confidence
how would more confidence help Heather's
life be different well confidence would
allow Heather to step into that role
right and she would be able to lose the
self-doubt and the Imposter syndrome and
the panicking and she'd be able to act
like the leader that the organization
promoted her to be right without all the
like nervousness and crap going on in
her head what about you let's get
selfish
what would more confidence allow you to
do that you're not currently doing
would you be able to say no
would you be better with boundaries are
there more risks you would take is there
a conversation you've been avoiding with
yourself or someone else would you be
able to stand up for yourself Advocate
more for yourself ask for what you need
what about work would you be more
visible would you speak up more all of
that that you just envisioned it's all
within your reach rule number three is
talk with ease with Vanessa van Edwards
for folks who have a hard time making
conversation there's a science behind
having a good conversation right yeah
and the good news is is the science of
conversation it can be used in any
situation whether it's professional
networking events business meetings
colleagues and also it's the same for
social parties New Friends Meeting
in-laws for the first time luckily the
science is the same whether you love
conversation or you don't okay so let's
talk about the first rule you say is
your intention yeah and this is actually
the one that we most often forget so the
best conversations and the best
conversationalists they always set the
intention for the conversation and this
helps award against you know those
awkward lulls or pauses that doesn't
happen when you set an intention so what
I want you to think about before you
meet someone before you go to an event
is what do you want to bring from the
event what do you want to bring to the
event so are you there to get new
business are you there to meet a
significant other are you there just
have a good time are you there to learn
something about someone just setting
that minor intention I always do it on
the car no matter where I'm going that
helps you guide your conversation for
the next few tips you'll notice you need
to have sort of that that guiding drive
to know what you want to talk about or
ask next so set your intention before
you even show it that's kind of like a
game plan right making sure you have a
plan exactly exactly it's setting up
your strategy for the night and again it
could be as simple as I just want to
laugh I just want to have a good time
because that's going to change the
direction of your conversation okay you
talk about approach yes so when you
think about conversation you usually
think about the first line but research
shows that our first impression doesn't
happen when you first hear someone it
happens when you first see someone so
actually the best conversationalist they
they always approach they almost start
their conversation on the approach so
what I want you to do is anytime you're
about to initiate conversation or you're
about to go to someone and introduce
yourself is set yourself up right so the
best first impression happens when you
have nice open body language so you want
your hands really visible out of pockets
not in touch into your purse not behind
your back helps with our trust cues
right and then having your shoulders
down and back anytime we Turtle it
signifies anxiety so shoulders down and
back and then your smile is actually
your opening line so when you smile at
something it warms them up right to them
going oh this person's about to talk to
me and it gets them sort of already
going it's like you're opening line a
little bit your smile right that's a
good idea uh and what would be a good
opener okay so everyone asks me now
what's a good pickup line what's a good
opening line there's a huge research
experiment that looked at almost every
single pickup line all the different
ways we start conversation let me guess
would it be a compliment first thing you
say is I like that ring or those boots
or that dress that Compliments are great
second and third the first one first one
the first one is I know this is going to
sound simple hello how are you oh by far
yeah that one by far and if you think
about it that's actually you don't
really want to say something too intense
when you first start so you have this
smile you go up you say hey how are you
I'm Vanessa whatever and then you go
into what's next and what's the next
parts you've already entered so you
don't even say your name you can see you
can say hey how are you I'm Vanessa
gotcha hey how are you that hey how are
you hello how are you it's actually so
nice because it's so easy and it's so
natural so don't think of anything crazy
just go with what's simple okay and then
what I want you to do is look for what's
called conversation Sparks
so conversation Sparks this is the
difference between a dazzling
conversation and kind of like a meh
conversation so conversation Sparks are
the non-verbal cue is when you're
engaging curiosity when you're engaging
someone to vote wow this is that's
really interesting and can I teach you
the non-verbal sign for Sparks sure so
across cultures across genders and races
there is one thing that everyone does
when they are super engaged and it's the
eyebrow raise
oh so you just did it just anytime
anytime someone says something
interesting we go oh that's what you're
looking for you're looking for the
topics the conversations the stories
that make them go oh really that means
you're really listening that means
you're not just going into boring so
what I want you to think about is you
set your intention right so maybe your
intention is to get to know your in-law
better right so what you'd be doing is
asking questions you're trying to look
for likes Mutual likes do you like this
restaurants vacations do we have similar
hobbies that we like and then you're
looking for that oh I love the baseball
game last night and then you know you've
hit it you've hit a spark and then you
can go down that hole on that rabbit
hole in the conversation so you're
looking for the spark the eyebrow raise
when you set that intention that's what
you're looking for the whole time okay
um ending a conversation my husband and
his family can never end and I don't
know how they do it but they can never
end a conversation It's the funniest
thing so we we don't think about ending
conversation is important but actually
your last impression is just as
important as your first impression so
here's what you do here's a really easy
way if you ever want to end a
conversation first mention it's called a
future mention so hey what are you up to
this weekend what are you doing later
today it actually shifts the focus from
present to future oh yeah yeah and then
they talk about oh yeah this weekend you
know I'm gonna go to a I'm gonna go to
the hike in Forest Park right that's
your cue to say well it was so great
speaking with you I wish you the best of
luck on that hike I hope it's great fun
so actually that future mention is a
nice little sorry yeah and it's a really
clean nice polite way to thank them for
the conversation and then wish them the
best of luck on whatever their future
Endeavor is that's a good idea easy
let's let's say you're at a party and
you want to make sure that someone feel
comfortable coming up to you what would
be good body language oh I love it okay
so um what you want to look for for
yourself and others is the pivot out so
whenever you're trying to approach two
people or three people anytime they're
both facing each other so their toes are
aligned you know they're probably not
open anyone else they're having
conversations don't interrupt don't
interrupt them so when you want to be
approached or you want to approach
someone else look for the pivot out
that's when someone's uh they're talking
to each other but their body is actually
angled out their toes are angled out
that means they're much more available
to approach and you want to do the same
so if you're talking to someone you
still want people to come up to you make
sure you pivot out towards the room that
signals people that you are open
physically and literally and I would
guess to get off your cell phone oh my
goodness I mean I hope that that goes
without saying the worst thing you can
do is people it's a habit for a lot of
people and they assume that they anybody
can come up and talk to them but if I
see someone on their cell phone I'm not
going to approach them and the problem
is is when we get nervous and we have no
one to talk to what do we do we're like
I'm going to pretend to text right so
the problem is it's this bad cycle you
don't have anyone to talk to so you
pretend to text and then no one comes up
to you so what I would say is you're
much better off going to get a drink
always have something in your hand it
feels nicer to have something in your
hands right and plant yourself right
where people exit the bar or the food
because that's sweet spot that's where
everyone's like I have no one to talk to
right so be that person who's like hey
so what do you what are you drinking
what'd you get doesn't this food look
great hey hello how are you yeah gotcha
plant yourself right there also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is reframe your
thinking with Alex hermosi if you think
about us as kids right like how do you
how do you Orient yourself of the world
you get reinforced or punished at all at
all phrases directly indirectly but you
get reinforced or punished and the
things you get reinforced you do more of
the things you get punished last up
right like that's just how how we how we
learn Behavior how we learn to function
Society Right Touch the thing ah it
hurts it's that's we got punished okay
you know you uh your parent tells you to
sit down and be quiet and eat
and you learn to sit down and shut up
and eat and then we wonder why adults
don't move because we're told to sit
when we're running around right we learn
at school sit down and be quiet 100 and
we and we wonder why uh we eat so much
when the reward for everything we did
when we were a kid was food right we
wonder these things so the reason
external validation is so hard at least
for me is because it's how I learned
everything is because external
validation gave you know gave me the the
directional guidance of what's good and
what's not and then as you get older
it's where am I going to get that
validation from and so I would say that
my external validation
um comes is still 100 there it just
comes from different sources so I'm more
selective on Whose validation I want so
how much external validation do you need
in order to
overcome this belief to go all in and do
it in half the time yeah no I think I
just I need to be able to validate
myself and that's fundamentally I think
having Titus said this he said like if
you need someone else's
if you need here's this quote it's so
good but it's basically like
you need to be able to give you don't
need to swear to somebody else you
should be able to swell your swear to
yourself and bear witness to yourself
because your word should be good enough
so you need to eliminate external
validation right from you feeling good
enough probably yeah it's probably that
like obviously you need it's good to
have feedback in life and so I think
that's why it's it's also difficult for
some in general because it's not
eliminate or have more of it's to what
degree and from whom and about what and
so then it gets a little bit more
complex but even using those different
lenses I think it's it's good to unpack
it for anyone who's listening which is
like okay
Layla said this so this is not mine
um but most times when we're afraid of
something
it's not actually like this amorphous
crowd that we're afraid of it's like one
or two people's opinion like it's your
dad or it's your whatever it is right
and you're worried about what they're
gonna think and they're not even
thinking about you but you think they're
thinking about it they're thinking about
their dad
whatever it is right and so she restated
this earlier on to Mike like when we
were together five years ago she was
like are you and she like made me name
the person it wasn't my dad it was
somebody else for this particular thing
she was like are you gonna let this guy
stop us from getting what we want wow
and it was like when I saw it it was
like looking in front of me I was like
she's like what if this guy hates you
and thinks you're terrible is that a
worthy enough reason to still keep going
and I was like yeah just like them let's
go you know what I mean yeah and so she
was very good with that rule number five
is reveal uncertainty with Brendan
burchard reveal uncertainty
this one is the opposite Dynamic of how
I used to think of confidence right we
think of confident people as people are
just like you know it's like Wonder
Woman right is confident we think of
Superman is confident who just knows
everything really what it turns out to
be high performers are a lot listen to
this High performers are a lot less
Superman and a lot more Clark Kent
that's what it turned to be in all the
research with millions of data points in
all of my conversations High performers
were much more likely to reveal
things like
I don't know
things like how
I'm I'm unsure
things like how do you think this should
go things like could could you kind of
help me with this
like high performers literally
explicitly share that they don't know
how it's going they don't know how it's
supposed to go that they need some help
that they need some mentorship that they
need some guidance
that's confidence
confidence is not holding back
the deck of cards of your weaknesses
confidence is a comfort with
vulnerability
and when people say vulnerability they
often don't know what they mean when
we're talking about vulnerability
specifically related to confidence and
high performance like measurable
outcomes the thing that we can measure
and see is that high performers in group
meetings in team meetings in social
situations more often share their
insecurity
they more often say I don't know how
this is supposed to go or you know
they'll be the person you know at that
fruit punch bowl who says you know what
I don't really know anybody here
um I don't really know how to start to
meet some of these people could you
introduce me to somebody
and that's how they handle the social
networking where they're awkward they
instead of just sitting back at the
punch bowl drowning their sorrows and
feeling bad about themselves they engage
the person next to them say hey you know
what I feel kind of awkward here I don't
know a lot of people could you introduce
me
that's how high performers are handling
these little situations in life they're
not the most confident person in the
meeting who goes I know everything here
they're the most confident going you
know what I don't know this here's my
question what do you guys think
and that is how you lead confidently you
reveal that you don't know everything
saying I don't know is power
not weakness
but you've been trying to do too many
things on your own
and that's one reason you don't have the
confidence you deserve at this stage of
your life
because see I don't wanna I didn't want
to start with my definition of
confidence for you because I want you to
be thinking about it but I'd like to
share it now that we've talked about
defining and measuring the way I look at
confidence is I think the companies that
matters the most is the confidence in
one's belief in our ability to figure
things out
that's what I believe confidence to be
do I believe in my ability to figure
things out not do I know things
because it's not always true there's a
lot of things I don't know
but do I believe in my ability to figure
things out
now there I'm confident not because I'm
smart because I'm good at asking I'm
good at saying you know what I don't
know how to do this what do you guys
think
and I hope this is settling in for you
because sometimes your confidence is so
low because you think your confidence is
correlated with what you know
versus what you're willing and able to
go figure out by revealing that you
don't know and rule number six the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is enjoy your own company with Matthew
McConaughey you knew that there is
something to be extracted from living
life so you know whether you would agree
with the statement that there's power
and loneliness
um certainly you were creating
situations from which you had the frame
of reference I can extract value from
this how did you get that frame of
reference like that's so useful but I
don't think most people have that
man you know I don't know exactly where
where I got it I mean I would say again
to call back that Australian year where
I did not have a choice where I was
forced into that situation and saw the
green light assets from being alone and
quite lonely
um I do think uh that there's Great
Value in being alone and if we are alone
and we get bored
and we don't like the company ding May
that light go off to say that does not
mean we need to pick up our phone to get
some attention or go to the bottle to to
to to to to to ease the anxiety or go
online to get some feedback to entertain
ourselves no it's actually a great time
to say no
sit here in that discomfort long enough
to go okay until you come out the other
side to go all right I'm good with me
again
now it's it's part of that I write about
it about traveling in general
ideally you don't go to a place you know
I always say that don't
I don't want to leave a place I travel
to until I get to the point of going ah
I could live here this could be my
existence as soon as I get to that point
then I'm like okay you go
now I can go that's the same thing in
the personal Journeys stick with it till
you get through the discomfortable to
uncomfortable times until you go you
know what I can spend time with myself I
could do this which I could do this
forever well then it's okay to go to
re-engage pick up your phone go see your
friends go have a drink what have you go
look for those things that are other
relationships in life but hopefully not
until there's Great Value in not doing
that until you go I'm good with me and
me for right now
self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things self-confidence
self-love self-respect it all comes from
deciding to do something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it
it's too hard it's too difficult it's
too scary
most people will let you off the hook
people around you will say yeah yeah
that's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
you let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
could have done it you know like that's
the worst feeling in the world that you
could have done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and padding on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it
they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments here's an example
so uh yesterday we had an insane
snowstorm here in Toronto I don't know
if we can it's kind of blurry you can't
see we had like you see some here behind
me it's like look at see that mountain
of snow behind me we had an insane
snowstorm we had probably the worst
snowstorm in Toronto Canada in the
decade I have not seen this much snow in
a crazy amount of time and so I'm going
for a walk
uh rocking and rucking is where you
carry a backpack so I'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as I'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside normally the
rocking alone is hard enough and I just
increased the weight in the backpack now
there's no path to walk on and this
morning I was walking through an area
and there was Zero path the snow is up
to my knees and I need to get through
so what's what are my options well I
could I could complain and turn around
right like oh I could look out the
window and say ah so much snow I'm not
gonna do that I'll do it when there's
less snow you know and then the next day
there's less snow there's still snow in
the next it's still snowing then all of
a sudden you just gave up on the Habit
right like you let yourself off the hook
to say I'll do it tomorrow and then and
then you never do it and then the
habit's gone and that's what you're
teaching yourself this is why it leads
to Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea you've already
reinforced the training you're training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea you don't do the thing when you say
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
start tomorrow and then you don't the
next time you come up with an idea guess
what you you've already reinforced the
pattern I don't follow through I'm not
going to do that I'm excited today but
tomorrow I won't follow through
so this is snow it's up to my knees
right up to my knees and I'm six one so
it's it's some serious snow like I gotta
walk through not quite that that's
that's probably taller than me uh I
don't have to walk through that much but
but up to my knees
I'm looking at it and I've got to go I
don't know
100 meters through this thing
and initially my thought was
why is there no path why is nobody
shoveled this why is nobody still
Blowfish like gotta get over there I got
a backpack on I'm rocking I'm sweating
like crazy I'm already exhausted now I
gotta go through this
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right everybody would have let me off
the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort Evan would have let
growth happen off the hook so it's okay
go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through that snow to
your knees
and as soon as I caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you look outside and
see the snow and not go just by default
not even catching the the conversation
with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment what
do you do do you do the difficult thing
or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice this is how we start to
either change our Identity or reinforce
our identity
so I looked at it I caught it and said
I'm going through let's go you know I
caught the negative thinking I caught
the Comfort Evan coming over walk around
go home nope not happening we're going
through we are going through we're gonna
make it through
and it was rough
you know I'm walking through I'm
freezing uh I'm taking one kind of giant
step at a time snow is getting all
through my boots all down my legs I I
almost slip and fall I have a coffee
that I that I picked up uh it's dripping
all over the place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best let's go
let's go Evan you got this man let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my head
combined with that
I'm also telling myself that you know
what not only am I doing this difficult
thing for me I'm also creating a path
for other people that the next person
who comes up against this 100 meters or
so
that now they will have not an easy time
but an easier time of crossing the same
path
so they can get across
so it's going to serve us
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true
maybe nobody ever comes across that path
maybe I didn't make it easier for the
next person maybe somebody comes five
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
I'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that I use one is
language so scary difficult or hard if
you say those things if you feel those
things if you text those things if you
write those things if you're talking to
yourself and you catch those things then
you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult hard everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself sane speaking
writing thinking scary difficult to
heart that's a that's a trigger it
should be a trigger it's a trigger for
me it should be a trigger for you to go
and do it do it go walk through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and I'm going to be cold and have snow
in my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships in your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly it's
like when your heart is going crazy like
that
it's usually because you should be doing
something you're afraid right now don't
again go don't go don't go standing on
the highway because it's scary and it
makes your heart race right don't be
stupid but most of the things that
you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right yeah
there usually it's other people's
opinions usually you're afraid of not
failing but somebody watching you fail
right you're gonna fail at something
who's gonna see you that's what we're
actually afraid of and that cannot be a
good enough reason it can't not anymore
if you're afraid of losing in front of
somebody if you're afraid of other
people's opinions if you are living your
life based off of the expectations and
Judgment of other people you will never
do anything great you will never live
your great life because somebody always
has a plan for what you should be doing
with your life you will never please
everybody it's not possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong I'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason to do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to do
and so learning to do difficult things
teaching yourself step by step RIP by
Brick one snow storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life
deserve a great life
when that comes on the other side of you
doing the things that are scary
difficult and hard no one is born with
self-confidence
zero
right every single one of us our
self-confidence was determined by how we
were raised the parents we had the
teachers we had the bosses we've had the
jobs we've had my sister worked for a
company for 17 years and her boss
destroyed her self-confidence she came
out of that job and she didn't realize
until she got into her new job how
afraid she was to make decisions because
of her boss and it took it took a while
for her to get her confidence back
um and so if somebody's insecure we have
to over and over and over again prove to
them
because we don't know where they came
from we don't know what kind of trouble
they got in before for being honest
right or what how they were raised we
don't know
and so we have to have to Total empathy
and just prove to them that that if they
make a mistake they're going to get
helped not hurt they're going to get
supported not yelled at and it the first
time they won't believe you they think
it's a game they think it's a con it's a
trick the second time maybe and we just
have to keep at it that every time I
used to have I used to have somebody on
my team who would regularly lie to me
right because she would rather lie to me
than tell me that she made a mistake
it was in and I could and if I saw the
lie I would ask so many questions to get
her to say to me I screwed up I'd be
like well this doesn't make sense
because I can't say you're lying to me
right I just say this doesn't make sense
this doesn't make sense if this adds up
to this then why is it that and she
would shoot the LIE would get bigger and
then she would yell at me about how I
don't trust her
and then at the end I have to be like
listen it clearly doesn't add up
I'm okay if it doesn't add up if you
made a mistake just tell me and I'm good
and we'll move on but when you deceive
me I'm going to ask you so many
questions to get to the truth
that it's going to get worse and worse
and worse I had to have that
conversation with her probably 50 times
before little cracks started to show
where she showed up to me once where one
number wasn't there and she looked at me
and said I made a mistake and I went
cool thanks
look Alan mullaley puts it brilliantly
he says you you have a problem you are
not the problem
right so if something goes wrong we have
a problem but you are not the problem
and that's the point is we've too many
times told people that they're the
problem
so I think it's just going to take time
and patience and you have to do the hard
work of helping that person build up
their confidence again what if this year
you made a commitment to blow your own
mind what if you made a commitment to do
what you've never done before say what
you never said before what if you made a
commitment to go to the edge and leap
and know you're either gonna soar or you
might fall but even if you fall you know
how to get back up
I don't know
what happens
and so
I just want to stop by to shake you up a
bit stop by to to find out who was who
does the world get when you play really
really big who does the world get
who does the world get when you say hold
on
hold on
I want to find out exactly who I can
become
hold on
I want to find out exactly who I can be
hold on I want to see exactly what I
want to do I want to see exactly how I
could play
hold on
hold on the best part of me
the best part of me is still showing up
hold on
the best part of me is still
it's still showing up hold on there's
more of me I'm not done yet like are you
willing to give the world notice I'm not
done yet
no no no no no I'm not done yet I have
so much more I have so much more I'm not
done yet
and when that happens and the world sees
you I got a question for you are you
ready to be seen
are you ready to be seen and are you
willing to be seen are you willing to be
seen in such a way that you say wait a
minute I'm Unapologetic
I'm Unapologetic about who I am I'm
Unapologetic I'm Unapologetic about what
needs to happen in order for me to show
the world who I am I'm Unapologetic I'm
just saying is that possible I'm I'm
reading it now
there's more for me yes there's more for
me yes yes type in chat there's more for
me there's more for me I'm ready and
willing to be seen unapologetically
unapologetically
I'm ready
I just stopped by
I don't know what your week looks like I
don't know what the last few days look
like I don't know what you're on your
way to this weekend but I stopped by to
say you are enough you showed up enough
it's time to press the gas and
accelerate it's time to press the gas
gas and Elevate to inspire more to serve
you to set healthy boundaries to say
bold yeses there's going to be something
that comes into your life and it's going
to require a bold yes not that shaky yes
well sorta sorta no no no that yes that
heck yes
yes and it's gonna require you to tell
somebody watch my fire watch my game
watch my shine
watch me I think that particular story I
was around like seven or eight years old
so I was a young child and it was a
little precocious thing to do so at that
age the only thing I could potentially
attribute it to and this is you know
pure speculation is a natural knowing I
think that Divine connection that we all
have to something greater than ourselves
um I feel in many ways like part of my
life is to Simply Be A Channel and to
listen and then to speak and share and
so the confidence and certainty
um I also want to say this I feel like I
oftentimes embody radically
um opposing things at the same time so
while a lot of people may watch our
videos or even read the book or see my
newsletters or or social and be like oh
my gosh she's so confident I need to be
real I'm also terribly filled with
self-doubt I am also a person that
question myself I'm also a person that
sits back and goes like I don't know is
this any good like I don't think it's
so both of those
of those can coexist I think
once I've had a chance to Grapple with
something for a little while and also
like road test it meaning I've had a
chance to play with people use Concepts
in real life work with them coach with
them see how things actually come out
how it impacts them and helps them
create results then the confidence
builds quite naturally so that happened
for me when I started as a coach again I
knew internally this is what I wanted to
do but I was very aware that I was like
I don't know crap right like I have to
build up that track record over time
same thing with like a program like
b-school I am very confident when we go
into our we only open it you know once a
year when we go into our promotional
period I get really fired up vision and
it's not false bravado it's because I'm
like I'm graduated 64 000 people and
I've literally been approached in
grocery stores from women who were on
the verge of homelessness who now run
multiple six-figure businesses and they
tell me like their children's
educational completely funded so when I
get fired up about anything like again
about this book I'm like no y'all I've
Road tested this please For the Love of
All Things holy just give it a try you
don't have to believe it try it before
you deny it though because this is good
so I think
um any confidence that you detect one I
just want to underscore it was born from
terrible insecurity that I still carry
around with me now and a lot of
self-doubt anytime I'm starting
something new or I'm stretching into a
new Zone and then the confidence side
just comes from also I've been doing
this now for 20 years like starting in
1999 and it's now 2021. you just I think
that's one of the best things about
maturity and that's one of the best
things about age is like you're like
I've been around the block a few times
and I've seen a couple things and I've
fallen on my face so it's all going to
be okay and I think probably one of the
other things again not to push it but
Vision I know you and I are both such
fans of books you know one of the
byproducts of adopting the belief that
everything is figureoutable is what I'd
like to call remarkable resilience
remarkable resilience and also a bit of
Courage because
this belief this notion that everything
is figureoutable is so a part of my
cellular DNA that I literally feel
Unstoppable not Unstoppable in the sense
that everything's gonna go my way
because it certainly does not and not
Unstoppable in the sense that I'm like
better than anybody else but Unstoppable
in this sense that if there is something
that I want to learn or experience or
achieve or help bring about I am 100
certain that if I'm committed to that we
will figure it out we will find a way or
we will make a way and when you have
that core belief embedded in you which
is what we teach you how to do in the
book it shifts everything because look
at how much our World Vision is filled
with uncertainty and filled with fear
and uncertainty that's natural right we
kind of kid ourselves into believing we
have some sense of control but when you
have this Bedrock belief that everything
is figure outable when you believe in
yourself that much all of a sudden
you're able to to stand in the tornado
of uncertainty because you know without
a shadow of a doubt that whatever comes
down the pike no matter how hard it gets
no matter how much you cry no matter how
much pain or suffering or confusion or
doubt there is you are going to rise and
you will make it through you know it
doesn't cost you anything not to believe
in yourself excuse me it costs you
nothing to believe in yourself but it
costs you everything not to
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to raise your confidence to the
next level check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there human beings don't usually stray
from that so if you consider yourself to
be a conservative person or a shy person
I know the way you move to some extent I
know the facial expressions the gestures
the way you use your body and it's all
consistent with the fact that human
beings